Harvey Weinstein faces up to 29 years in
prison after a jury convicted him of
rape and a criminal sexual act he left
the courtroom in handcuffs and then left
the building in an ambulance
dozens of allegations against a media
mogul fueled the rise of the me2
movement more than two years ago
Miriam Haley was one of the two main
witnesses in the trial Weinstein was
found guilty of a criminal sexual
assault against Mimi her powerful and
courageous testimony helped lead to his
conviction Gloria Allred is her attorney
good morning to you both thanks for
being here
good morning Mimi if I could start with
you one of the two charges as I said
that that Weinstein was found guilty on
was directly related to your testimony
what did it mean to you to hear that
verdict I was just a huge relief really
it was a huge relief that the jury got
it I felt just very grateful that they
that I'd been heard and and believed and
yeah I mean I'm still processing I think
but it was like just a relief did you
feel the jury may not rule in your favor
well I wasn't sure what was gonna happen
to be honest I wasn't you know I mean
the statistics say that most rapists go
walk so so I didn't know which way it
would go no but I'm just very relieved
and grateful and happy that that that
feels like we're making progress so that
this verdict demonstrates that cases
like yours can be brought and the
charges can be successful so I'm curious
what do you hope other survivors take
away from your experience and this
verdict well I mean I'm just I just
think that we're being educated about
the reality of sexual assaults and
sexual assault victims and what sexual
assaults usually are more often than not
involved it's it's not uh it's not
always just a stranger it is very often
somebody that the person knows you know
so and then with that comes an entire
other layer of processing you know when
it's somebody that you know there's a
whole other layer of processing where
you don't understand like an emotional
confusion why did this person do this
how could this person have done this to
me
so yeah that's what I hope that we are
more realistic from now on about sexual
assaults Gloria what impact do you think
this verdict is going to have on future
sexual assault cases including the next
Harvey Weinstein case well Anthony this
is the reckoning I mean this is the time
when we have the empowerment of women
when women are not only speaking up and
speaking out but willing to testify in a
court of law
under oath though the truth all truth
nothing but the truth so help them God
or to affirm that oath and that is a
whole different level because on this
level consequences can be imposed as a
result of Mimi's courage he could be
sentenced to 10 years to 25 years in
prison this is the most serious charge
in which he was convicted the criminal
sexual assault and that means that
others who were out there thinking of
hurting women or who already have
committed crimes of gender violence
against women should understand they may
be next because there are going to be
consequences and this is the way we
start to begin to stop violence against
women when those who are going to hurt
them know that there could be serious
consequences and even if you're rich
even if you're powerful even if you're
famous like Harvey Weinstein you are
also subject to the law and you don't
have a special license to hurt women so
it's because of her courage that this
has happened and we can't thank the jury
and the prosecutors enough Gloria
quickly were you surprised the jury got
caught up on the predatory sexual
assault trial charge and did not convict
well it's a very high burden of proof no
to prove guilt beyond a reasonable doubt
and I don't know if they were
compromises worth trading in the jury I
don't know we'll have to wait for the
jury to decide but whatever that took
place in the jury it's not a reflection
on Annabella I mean she was brave she
sacrificed so much time she went through
so much in this case I just I'm honored
to know her and she's a real hero as
Mimi is as Lauren is to the women's
movement to the victims rights movement
and we are moving forward for women as a
result of her courage the district
attorney called me me and the seven
other accusers one of eight women who
changed the course of history you know
and pulled our justice system into the
21st century right and I'll call it her
story because it's her story not his
story now and we're moving forward to
equal rights and equal protections for
women leave me hailey Gloria all right
thank you both for being here this thank
you thank you so much